we are at a very important Point not
least with policing in the UK the
protests that have taken place in recent
weeks and the protests that have already
been announced for the weeks ahead have
been a great test for the Metropolitan
Police and other police forces across
the UK and it is a test that they have
failed
monumentally now I know the policing
decision they've made part of the
policing decision
clearly is that they will observe the
crowd and they will see if anyone breaks
bre the law and if they do break the law
they may get a visit at some point later
from the police and they may be
arrested this happened in the 2000s with
Anam child and the group members of
almah harun there was a very similar
thing there was once actually an
occasion when um mun came to me
personally in the Streets of London and
I was amazed that the British police
didn't do more to protect me or
um well anyway and it turned out that
they were doing doing the same thing
which is they hang back in order to
arrest people later um well here's the
problem with that the world only sees
the crime being committed the world does
not see the
followup the world is very interested
and watching The Streets of London at
the moment and are horrified by what
they
see they do not see the tiny number of
arrests the Metropolitan Police has been
willing to actually carry out of people
who are supporting heraz on our streets
and not only that by the way Douglas we
saw a couple of years ago people who
drove down from Blackburn quite far away
from London to go into Jewish areas and
uh through megaphone shout rape Jewish
women kill Jewish women all of
them Fu the mothers F the daughters and
show the support mother Shut Them Up rap
the daughters to S
mess those people were arrested and not
prosecuted yes um maybe they should have
tweeted it yeah they should have um they
should have uh called them what was the
crime that Lawrence Fox committed again
that b the whole world crashing down a
few weeks ago they should have said they
wouldn't shag them which is the opposite
of what they seem to be wasn't that a
good should they should have gone
through Jewish era saying I wouldn't
shag that would have got the police
interested and probably offc come
that would have got the guardian going
for
months my God we've been diverted
haven't
we um here's the thing the the police uh
are also of course in this strange case
of several cases we now have on camera
of the police taking down the posters of
missing stolen Jewish children that have
been put up in London and other places
and as well as being ripped down by um
Muslims in the UK and leftists in the UK
they've also now been taken down by
police in the UK we have footage of the
metropolitan police taking down these
posters uh two things about that if I
may the first is we should follow the
example of some blue collor workers in
New York and elsewhere in America
recently who have found these scumbags
taking down posters and confronted them
if the police are not going to confront
people ripping down posters and trying
to hurt Jews on the streets of Britain
again I would like the public to do so
and I think the public should start to
do so and that is what will happen if
the police do not protect the public the
public will have to start protecting the
public the second thing may I just on
that
sure aren't we being slightly dishonest
at Douglas the demographic situation in
the UK is very different um it is I
don't I don't know that if I was to
challenge somebody in the street doing
that that I frankly at this point would
have the support of the people around me
I wonder if I might find myself in a
minority okay well what will happen at
some point is that a group of people
people who are in a majority will come
down from some other part of L of the UK
and they'll do it themselves and who
would say that that was a bad
thing at this point yeah at this point
if this is all all on the table oh
they're going to regret it the police
are going to deeply regret this so
that's the first thing the second thing
is uh and let me be as clear as possible
on this the police clearly seem to think
in the UK that the big problem is that
it is provocative to put up posters of
abducted Jewish
children and that is because it will
provoke Community tensions this by the
way is not a fringe view it is a view
clearly shared by a number of
politicians across the UK most
prominently certain Muslim politicians
across the
UK here let us be totally Frank if there
are people in the UK who are are
offended by the posters of missing
Jewish children they must leave the UK
we do not want them it is not Jews who
should be fearful in the UK it is the
people who would make Jews fearful they
must leave it is shameful to me that in
the last few weeks I have had friends
from around the world including Jewish
friends saying is it safe any longer to
come to England to come to Britain
specifically to come to
London it is not Jews who should fear
being in London it is the people who
would make them fearful so at some point
the Jews who are a very small minority
in the UK a little over
200,000 they are dwarfed by the large
size of the Muslim Community in the UK
at the moment but fine the non-muslim
population of the UK is far
larger and by and large in my experience
they are very good people the British
still have pride in their past that has
not been beaten out of them they still
have a sense of the goodness of our
nation of the pride of our nation of
what it has done in the past that we
should be grateful for and proud of and
what it might still do now despite
Decades of indoctrination to try to tell
us that we are wicked that is really
only believed by a small number of
people who happen to have control of
many of the major institutions and have
a disproportionate voice in the media
and a disproportionate in what used to
be called
Academia fine we'll do this without
them